[Music]
all right
sister wife star Christine Brown engaged
what is it you're looking for in a new
partner kindness real just kindness in a
romantic relationship for sure seems
Christine's found that with boyfriend
David Wooley after four months of dating
he's wonderful and romantic and so kind
and everything I've been looking for
Christine shared the exciting news with
these picks featuring her husband to be
and her new diamond ring check out this
close-up of the sparkler the TLC star
gushes in the caption we're engaged
David popped the question very
romantically and I said yes I'm so
excited and just live in Bliss every day
just he's absolutely a dream come true
Christine's engagement comes nearly two
years since her split from ex-husband
Cody Brown Nobody's a prisoner in this
family I firmly believe plague me was
what I was supposed to do and everything
and that's all great and now though yeah
I get to be done so it's more like a
personal strength I said moving forward
I didn't look back I never looked back
following the end of their marriage
Christine relocated from Arizona to Utah
and that's where she met David
our confessions okay so I just have to
tell you I am dating someone exclusively
on Valentine's Day the couple went
Instagram official Christine calling
David the love of my life I have more
than I've ever felt before because I was
able to make steps for my future and for
my present and so I just feel more
confident as well and good news travels
fast Christine's former sister wife and
friend Janelle Brown who also split from
Cody couldn't be happier commenting on
Christine's post hooray I'm super close
with Chanel that's that's of course very
different uh just Janelle and I are to
probably just continue I don't know if
you can be Sister Wives you know if
you're not really but I just consider
telling myself she just always will be
despite divorcing Cody we know
Christine's Sister Wives Journey will
continue I made like a promise to like
Cody and everybody else and I will stay
with Sister Wives as long as we have the
show just to be fair it's what our
family's been doing for so long and so
no I absolutely I feel like it would be
disloyal if I you know decided to not be
part of the show but as far as if we'll
see Christine walk down the aisle on the
TLC series we'll have to wait and see
absolutely that'd be just fun as heck
congrats to the happy couple
[Music]
thank you